لقد رأيت هذا الاتجاه المتنامي عبر الإنترنت من الشباب والشابات يحلقون شعرهم تمامًا ويحتضنون الحلاقة ، وهو شيء كنت دائمًا مهتمًا به يتم تسجيله في الاجتماع ، هذه هي المرة الأولى التي ترشد فيها شخصًا ما من الحلاقة رؤوسهم خلال جائحة عالمي ما هو نوع الأجهزة التي أحتاجها للتأكد من أنني أفعل ذلك بشكل صحيح في المنزل حتى يكون لديك مشط وفرشاة شعرك ، لقد جئت بالفعل لدي فرشاة شعر لا أفعلها أعتقد أنني أتعامل مع واحدة من هذه قبل ما هو الصف الذي ستضعه على كليبرز ، اثنان وثلاثة وأربعة ، هذا ما يجب علينا العمل معه إذا كنت تريد أن تقصر ، يمكنك دائمًا أن تذهب هي تجيب وأنت تعلم أنها SDO وظيفة تقول إنه لا يمكنك التمسك بها مرة أخرى ، لذا سنبدأ من الجانبين وسنعمل على ذلك مباشرة في الجزء الخلفي من الرأس بشكل مستقيم مستقيم مستقيم الشعر المستقيم الذي ينطلق بالفعل هناك ، نعم لذلك عندما الحصول على الجزء الخلفي من عقد الخاص بك لا تفوت أي ثنائية
من الغريب بشكل خاص أنه من الصعب ثني
ذراعك بهذا الشكل ، فلننتقل
إلى الجانب الآخر ، خذ الأمر ببطء
شديد ببطء ولا تنسى هذا الشيء
هنا من السهل تفويته هو أن
المظهر الجميل بالنسبة لك هذا طبيعي جيد
اتجاه شعر معظم الناس عندما
ينمو يكون لأسفل من التاج لذلك هذا
هو تاج رأسك ، نعم كل الكلمات
ولأسفل للبدء مباشرة من الأمام
واعمل فقط على التاج والعودة
إلى الخلف مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
نعم  الآن ما سنفعله هو
أن نبدأ في الأساس من الأمام ثم
سنقوم فقط بتخطيها على
الرأس بالكامل ، وكلما فعلت
ذلك ، كلما قمت بإنشاء
طول متساوٍ يبدو هذا  حسنًا حقًا ،
أود أن أقول إنه يشبه إلى حد ما تقاطع
بين بيضة وبراد بيت ولكن
أشبه بالبيضة ، لذا انظر إلى كل جانب لذلك
ليس سيئًا أنك تعلم أنه يبدو جيدًا ،
فقد كان في الواقع في محل الحلاقة الخاص بك
الآن وقد انتهيت  مع نتيجة
مثل هذه ، ما رأيك يا
جميل سآخذ هذا نعم أعتقد
أنك